it's the debate which divides america
on one side those who believe access to
abortion is standard healthcare and a
human right
on the other those who believe abortion
is in their own words murder
the battle is erupting once more for
half a century a woman's right to
abortion has been protected by june it's
likely that will have been snatched away
a newly right-leaning supreme court
poised to revoke a constitutional right
for the first time in history
elizabeth warren one of america's most
recognizable politicians is seething
i've never seen you so angry you seem to
be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day
for decades
they have been out there plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices
so they could have a majority on the
bench who would accomplish something
that the majority of americans do not
want 69 of people across this country
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe vs wade
we don't want to dismember children in
the womb
senator warren is drowned out by the
pro-life protesters archie is another
who has traveled to be here a lot of
these states would ban abortion even in
the case of rape or incest how does that
make you feel i obviously would never
find myself in that situation
at all i think what needs to happen is
we surround that woman with all the love
and support
president biden has struggled to
confront the issue head-on this leak
forcing him to say the word abortion
allowed for the first time in his
presidency
concerns me a great deal
that we're going to after 50 years
decide a woman does not have a right to
choose the mental limits of the supreme
court decision
number one
but even more equally as profound is the
rationale used
and it would mean that
every other decision
relating to the notion of privacy
is thrown into question
these women are from florida and
mississippi two of the states that would
immediately enforce a near total ban on
abortion if roe is overturned women's
lives are in danger you know it takes
away choice it takes away medical
autonomy and bodily autonomy we already
are close to being a third world country
in america with women's rights
i don't honestly understand what's
happening in our country everything just
feels like it's going backwards
the fact this draft decision has been
leaked to a political website ahead of
time is startling the privacy of the
supreme court is usually paramount it's
going to be hard for the court to trust
each other
i can't remember an event like this in
the history of the court so if you can't
form consensus share thoughts and the
whole rule of law process breaks down
an inquiry has been launched to find the
source of the leak but the bigger
question is how america 50 years after
legalizing abortion has come to this and
what happens next martha kellner sky
news washington